I'm really sorry that we've started late
I think this is one thing we can
legitimately blame the mainstream media
for chances are somewhere near you
during this campaign something like this
will happen you explain what Labour's
going to do labour is going to abolish
tuition fees a workshop in Durham led by
momentum the Jeremy Corbyn supporting
organisation to Train labour members to
connect with you better part of a
sophisticated network of events digital
activities and the like taking place
every day just beneath the sound and
fury of the national campaigns and
[Applause]
they're not alone in their enthusiasm
across the country just today in
altering ham Chingford Croydon and
Blackpool to name but a few thousands of
activists turned out in force as the
Durham lots are up from the Durham
miners hall old labor meeting the new
the question is whether any of this with
a party's back against the wall can make
enough of a difference on the streets of
Durham it was tough going
very enthusiastic but the price hasn't
been the most positive reception on the
doorstep here a lot of people talking
about coal bin saying it's too far left
brexit coming up a bit but Corbin is a
the issue that I've heard is brexit one
and people just want to get it done I've
explained to them that the Labour Party
policy is the only one that actually
gives them a choice yeah and people have
listened to that potentially it could be
yeah common theme for this morning is
that no mrs. or no wants to talk to the
activist really interfiled
they will talk to us which they'll do a
bit they'll only do off-camera but there
is a lot of people are very angry the
Labour Party the only thing that can be
said for Labour Party is that there is
equally angry with the Conservative
Party
it's like politics is being done to them
and there they're just sheltering the
sheltering in their homes not just cuz
it's winter but just because it just had
enough soon after in the neighbouring
seat one of the left's rising stars
Laura pitcock was launching her campaign
and the activists could enough of it
[Music]
excellent shoot good yeah we're on the
doorsteps good yep how do you think it
feels by comparison to 2017 I think it's
much more positive more positive people
in here exciting
there are as well when you're on the
doorstep people are up for it the energy
inside the Corbin tent is electric but
sometimes it's as if the world outside
is still running on gas that it doesn't
convert the activists our Labour's
powerful messengers but what if the
country has stopped this thing who's got
all Sky News encountered on